[Music]
I don't know how many times I had heard
or at least observed some form of the
idea that classic overused cliché that
ones whole life flashes before their
eyes in the conscious moments right
before dying I had heard it a lot I know
that I had even heard it used in plenty
of non death related instances when
people just wanted to add a little
grandiose to a situation or story I
myself had probably even used it in a
story or two it is of course one of
those things that doesn't really make
much sense while you're alive though
after all how could one's entire life
flash before their eyes presumably the
use of the word eyes here is meant to
represent sort of the visualization
center of the mind as opposed to
literally the eyeballs in the head but
even still how could the mind speed up
years worth of experience is so fast
that it could all be perceived and
recollected in minutes or even seconds
and still be discernible I had always
wondered at the absurdity of the notion
whenever it was mentioned or represented
in something now in this moment on the
side of the road contorted and lacerated
I was about to find out exactly what it
meant I didn't know exactly how much
blood the human body could lose before
dying but it didn't take long for me to
realize that I was getting pretty close
I could feel my body shutting down and
started experiencing weird pains that
didn't hurt so much as confused and
nauseated me harder to describe than it
was to feel I could also hear that
people were saying things to me that
were indicative of someone dying things
like please don't close your eyes just
hold on a little bit longer it's going
to be okay an ambulance is on the way
stuff like that but with different words
and in a much more pleading dramatic
tone they all knew as well as I did
though what was happening and that no
amount of force of will to keep my eyes
open was going to help match death if it
were to come at this point it felt much
better to just close my eyes anyway it
somehow relieved the pain a little I
accepted that I was dying by this point
wasn't even really a conscious choice my
body knew my mind knew after this moment
of acceptance my mind certainly did race
at a sort of flash like speed but mostly
it felt comparable to that of what I
would imagine a lucid panic attack feels
like on 20 cups of coffee I didn't see
everything from my life and there was no
apparent rhyme or reason or order of
which I did I did however feel a great
sense of regret
as I ruminated across all the feelings
and thoughts and memories that
appeared I thought about who I would
never see again and what I would never
do again I thought about how I wouldn't
see what colors were going to be in the
next evening sunset how I would never
brush my teeth again how I would never
feel the air running over my skin or
flowing into my nose again I thought
about the low hum of all the appliances
in my house that I would never hear
again then I thought about what I never
saw or did but always wanted to all the
times I never told people how I felt or
how much I cared about them all the
opportunities I let go because I was
scared all the habits and problems in my
life that I always wanted to change but
never did then I thought about how much
time I wasted worrying about these
things the time I wasted hating myself
the time I wasted being unhappy in the
time I wasted getting mad at myself for
being unhappy when I should have been
happy I thought about how I rarely ever
fully synced up with what I knew I
should have done or how I should have
thought how I seem to always deceive or
sabotage myself in the process I would
get close to the sort of ideal or
sublime that I always knew existed in
each moment but then I would run the
other way however upsetting and sad this
whole part was it kind of fit my
Hollywood expectations of dying which
only added to the disappointment it was
anticlimactic
like predicting the end of a movie now I
found myself getting upset and angry
about the disappointingly rational and
predictable process of getting upset
angry and regretful while dying even
here I was literally regretting my final
moments of life as they occurred how
foolish could I be I wondered what kind
of being hates itself or brings
suffering onto itself knowing that
hating itself and suffering makes them
miserable
what kind of being spends their final
moments alive being miserable about
their life in this ridiculous
self-loathing rumination as if coerced
by something that was predetermined to
happen at a certain moment of the body
and brain turning off a sudden pause
occurred a pause that felt much more
like a flash than the previous flash
that was occurring it was not a flash of
speed but a sudden flash of ceasing
speed like a camera flash to a little
rodent it stunned me and stopped
everything as if my consciousness had
finally surrendered told by my
subconscious that there was no self or
life left to defend for the first time I
felt free not free in the sense that I
was able to do whatever I wanted
quite the opposite free in the sense
that in only a few moments
I literally would not be able to do
anything I wanted in this I suddenly
became so majorly indifferent to
everything that everything became clear
I saw myself through an entirely
different lens as if a smudge on my
pre-existing lens had been cleared off
revealing what had always been
obstructed from me I continued thinking
for a little while
but my thinking was different there
wasn't critical rational or judgmental
for the first time in my entire life I
saw who I really was while alive I
understood that I had a conscious brain
and unconscious brain I had learned
about these fairly rudimentary
psychology concepts as a young child and
considered the implications of them
frequently throughout my life however
these terms never really translated in
any practical or helpful way at least
not for me if anything they only made me
feel like I had two parts of my brain
the part that was me and the part that
wasn't I was of course my conscious
brain and my unconscious brain was
something else that I was constantly
fighting or trying to conquer this
wasn't wrong per se but it wasn't
exactly right either at a minimum it
certainly wasn't helpful it took being
mangled on the side of a road with parts
of my brain seemingly being turned off
to actually understand it
sure I was never my unconscious brain
but I was never my conscious brain
either just like I was never my heart or
my hand or anything else on its own I
was never even solely what was contained
inside my body I was everything in and
out I was the puppet and the puppeteer
the puppeteer being sort of my
unconscious brain but also way more than
my unconscious brain it was what made
and fueled my unconscious brain what
made my brain as a whole what made
everything admittedly while alive this
might have sounded confusing or
pretentiously cheesy or like spiritual
nonsense or even cliche if someone had
told me perhaps it is to you right now
most things about life while I was alive
though sounded confusing pretentiously
cheesy or like spiritual nonsense
however after a certain point of being
viscerally aware of your approaching
mortality you sort of don't think about
things like that anymore you stopped
putting this filter of judgment on top
of sincerity or cliche archetypal
experiences regardless even if you're
not in this state if you can humor me
just for a moment imagine the puppet and
puppeteer I referred to consider how a
puppeteer is only a puppeteer if it has
and manipulates a puppet
if there was no such thing as a puppet
there would be no such thing as a
puppeteer and vice versa the puppet is
not the puppeteer and the puppeteer is
not the puppet but without the other
both ceased to exist in the context of
their definitions I spent my whole life
thinking I was the puppet contained by
the strings the consciousness contained
by the brain the brain contained by the
body the body contained by the world and
as a result I spent my whole life at war
against everything I felt contained by I
spent my life pulling at the strings
trying to rip myself from them these
strings and my pulling at them however
was the source of all the self sabotage
and self-loathing all the divisions and
limits between what I wanted for myself
and what I never could have I was
contained by strings and furthermore I
added constant tension to them by
pulling at them making things worse by
always trying to make things better
a little earlier I would have been
gravely regretful of this realization
far more than my earlier regrets I would
have tormented over the idea that I
ruined my life missing the entire point
making things worse than they had to be
however I did not get mad or regretful
at all by this point my conscious sense
of self had fully given up on defending
itself I didn't care I recognized that I
had no choice in these strings existing
in the first place they were written in
my DNA they were written in the DNA of
my DNA and furthermore I had no choice
in pulling at them either if I was both
the puppet and the puppeteer even the
act of pulling on these strings and
struggling towards something was in fact
part of the whole show my being came
with strings and my being came with the
desire to pull at the strings so what
was I to do other than to live with
strings and pull at them I spent my
whole life fighting Who I was often
hating who I was trying to be happier or
better or something sometimes I would be
successful but even then would mostly
just return to the same starting point
beginning the fight all over again but
of course this was because I never was
who I thought I was this part of myself
that I always thought I was in a fight
with turns out it was actually more of a
dance and without the constant push and
pull without the struggle without
seemingly having missed the point there
would have been no point at all no dance
no show
the things I could have changed I did
the things I couldn't I didn't and the
things I didn't know I should have I
never thought to try I was exactly who I
could have been exactly who I needed to
be I did everything right by doing a
great deal of things wrong there was
nothing to regret regret implies that I
chose how things went but I never really
had a choice at all
I didn't choose who I was anymore or any
less than anything else that is was or
ever will be no more than a dog chooses
to be a dog or rock chooses to be a rock
I just woke up and was I didn't choose
who my parents were
who my brain was like when my body was
like well my first sight was my first
conscious experience my anxieties my
fears or any of what these things caused
me to do now I was about to fall asleep
forever in the last choice I never made
holding the thing that I had been
chasing my whole life what had been the
source of my misery was now in the final
moment the source of my bliss the source
of my self-discovery my acceptance of
who I really was while alive and Who I
am now
while dead
you